nobody that's a leader
would not do what i did and i know
there's a risk there's a danger but
that's okay
[Music]
i just left walter reed medical center
and i learned so much in coronavirus
don't be
afraid of it you're going to beat it we
have the best medical equipment don't
be afraid of it felt great like better
than i have in a long time
be afraid of it i didn't feel so good
don't be afraid of it you're going to
beat it we have to put
on a virus don't be afraid of it and now
i'm better
maybe i'm immune i don't know be afraid
of it
don't let it dominate don't let it take
over your life be
afraid of it don't let that happen
you're the greatest country in the world
you're afraid of it
as your leader i had to do that i knew
there's danger do it but i had to do it
[Music]
but don't let it dominate your lives get
out there be careful
we have the best medicines in the world
and it all happened very shortly and
they're all getting approved
and the vaccines are coming momentary
[Music]
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
[Music]
lives
[Music]
to help treat patients battling a
current infection convalescence
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives we provided 48 million dollars to
fund the mayo clinic study that tested
the
efficacy of convalescence
an extraneous plasma there left over um
we are going to see donald trump today
um we've not seen donald trump for a
while
but he's scheduled to give a rose garden
press conference at the top of the hour
it's been a disastrous day for trump
once again
um he officially lost georgia
that's the big news georgia has been
called hold on i have a bunch of
different things here for you guys where
is my georgia
uh element for this stream
um oh maybe i don't even have it
hold on i thought i had my georgia stuff
um no i guess i don't well in any case
georgia has been called for joseph r
biden jr
and um it looks like george i'm sorry
that
georgia puts 306 electoral votes up on
the board for joe biden which is the
same number of electoral votes that
trump had
in 2016. um in 2016 trump lost the
popular vote
where is that coming from
oh that's my voicemail elements which i
had for you guys a little bit later i'm
just going to mute that for now
cnn called georgia washington post
called georgia others have called
georgia at this point in time
so remember in 2016 trump lost popular
by three million
one electoral with 306. that was called
the landslide by prompt
by kellyanne conway c-o-n like a con
she cons people kaylee morgan annie
everybody 306 even though you lost by 3
million was a landslide
this year we have biden with 306
winning the popular vote by five to six
million
so by their definition these are not
words i l
i'm looking to apply by their definition
this is a landslide and are they
admitting it no they're actually saying
they're actually saying trump won and
just to start getting
some of these things out of the way
because i have so many things to play
for you
here is kaylee being asked on fox
business
by stuart varney whether trump will
attend biden's inauguration and she says
he has to go to the inauguration because
he'll be the one being inaugurated take
a listen to this
are you prepared to say that the
president will that president trump will
definitely attend the inauguration
again you know that's many that's many
steps away here uh we're talking january
and
uh president trump believes he will be
president trump have a second term
and litigation is the first step many
steps away from that
it would look pretty bad if he did not
attend the inauguration it would sound
like
it looked like sour grapes wouldn't it i
i think the president will attend his
own inauguration he would have to be
there in fact
yeah so anyway at this point we so
we don't even really need to pay
attention to that trash anymore
because we we we now have widespread
reporting that trump knows he's not
going to win
trump's talking about launching a news
network to crush fox
trump's talking about announcing his run
for 2024.
trump knows he's not going to be the
next you know he's not going to be the
president for the next four years
he is um it's theater and he's trying to
raise money
to retire some of his campaign debt you
know there are there are folks on fixed
incomes
who really can't afford to be donating
money to trump but they're giving him
money thinking this might help trump win
even trump doesn't think he's going to
win and half of the money they donate to
for recounts
um is going to be used to retire
campaign debt you don't have to take my
word for it look at the fine print
on those fundraising emails that i know
many of you have been
uh have been receiving so that's that as
far
as mega nanny is concerned now i have
so many things to play for you guys
today
i have new unhinged voicemails i have
emails i want to show you
i have uh memes i have music
i have a preview of my interview with uh
with vosh
vosh destiny [ __ ] iii is how i'm
now referring to him that interview
we'll be publishing in about three hours
on my youtube channel
i just have so many different things i
don't even know where to start but i
guess
let's do let's do this i now have a full
interview
this was supposedly lou dobbs
interviewed this woman on the left
i guess is a whistleblower of sorts
one of the people who signed uh those
affidavits
about voter fraud and let's just listen
to what she had to say a little bit
how did that happen so the workers are
handed
ballots in stacks of 50s stacks
they are referred to as batches oh my
god
they run them through the tabulators
what accent is that by the way when the
ballot has any kind of a mark on it
it'll stop how many how many different
it sounds like the word it has three
different vowels in it i've no
i'm not i'm not familiar that's not
staten island i don't think that's
staten island
okay the tabulator will stop completely
yeah computer will put up an
error and it'll say you know bailout
number
25 has
an error and right so the process would
this is pretty devastating stuff guys
would be to take
ballot number 25 as well as all of the
other ballots that had already went
through the tabulator
off put them back in a pile
put ballot number 25 on top of the stack
discard the whole batch and re-scan it
yeah joe biden's new chief of staff
ronald klein
was reportedly visibly shaken by this
interview
and that's and instead they went through
that process several times
describe the night shift chaos that you
do here's where it gets good
um food
food vans apparently showing up but not
with food
with uh ballots uh apparently give us a
sense of what happened well they keep
talking about curing ballots of course
it's a food van if you're curing ballots
if you're sauteing ballots
if you're grilling ballots obviously
that sounds like food work to me
there so they're um so i worked a
24-hour shift
um i started at 6 a.m and i got off at 6
00 p.m
or 6 a.m uh the next day right um
so i started at 6 a.m november 3rd
get off at 6 00 am november 4th
beautiful so i was there during their
day shift and their night shift
the city provides the workers with
food for their shift well they only had
enough food for
one-third of their workers
there you go so that is the reason why
they were claiming that these vans were
were
brought in yep reportedly they also
showed up exclusively with matzo ball
soup
and chocolate babka and anti-semitism
exploded based on the the food items
that were delivered also
they were there was hanukkah brisket as
well and people were like brisket oh my
god
but these vans did not have taken out of
them
and the vans the vans that showed up
lou dobbs trying to figure out what the
claims are
is is almost as good as the claims
themselves
um they were supposed to be filled with
food what did
what did they have in them do you know
balance never saw anything being brought
out of the vans i know that whatever was
being
brought out of the vans was being
brought out of the back of the vans
right but um which is suspicious i mean
who brings anything out the back of a
van
allowed over in that area at all but the
vans were definitely not big enough to
be carrying
enough food for two-thirds of those
workers yep they supposedly also had
some of those fake meats like
soy-based meats and a lot of workers
were
infuriated by that
well it it's all very suspicious
it's all completely there was a food van
and there was only enough food for a
third of the workers give the state to
trump guys
it's very clear that you have witnessed
highly irregular
activities in that counting session and
david i want to turn to you
yeah then they go to this guy so anyway
that's
that's pretty explosive aggressive
claims as all of you guys
can understand and uh kamala reportedly
uh uh looking for consulting work
because she after seeing that interview
kamala was like i'm there's no way i'm
gonna get to be vice president
at this rate so uh really really crazy
stuff
all right we've gotten that out of the
way if you're just joining me
it's been basically hold on wednesday
it's been nine days since we've seen
donald trump
publicly other than when he did a wreath
laying on
veterans day before tweeting election
conspiracies trump went and did a
wreathlang
and it's not been a good day for trump
um his lawyers are quitting left and
right
georgia's been called for joe biden
arizona election witness confessed to
being a trump campaign lawyer's business
partner in court so the arizona
fraud claims have completely fallen
apart there
so arizona's done as possible fraud
new york times law firms are pulling
back
from trump's election fight porter
wright was representing trump in a
lawsuit in pennsylvania
they just bailed um jones day lawyers
say that they're not going to take on
any new election litigation
like it's all just going very very bad
and we'll cover this on the monday show
but needless to say it's not been a good
day for donald trump
and i guess the idea is trump's going to
speak about operation
warp speed which is this program to try
to get
the the coronavirus vaccine the vaccine
that now is the closest which is the bio
end tech pfizer vaccine was developed
in germany by turkish immigrants and
will be manufactured by
pfizer which took no operation warp
speed money but regardless of that trump
wants credit for it much like trump
tried to take credit for barack obama's
veterans choice program trump wants
credit for a german vaccine
developed by turkish immigrants
manufactured by
one of the american companies that took
none of trump's money
he will i'm sure today tried to take
credit for it
and it will be it will be pretty pretty
wild stuff
let me say a few thank yous we did just
have eight people
grab memberships at joinpackman.com
which i really appreciate
we are also counting twitch subs and now
at 2500
that is five putting us at 13.
um thank you very much i very much
appreciate that let me look at just a
couple of super chats here
a drum twitter asked whether my
interview with peter joseph was
rescheduled yeah he no call no showed
sadly
um it we we rarely get no call no shows
but it was just
missing i hope he's okay um but uh
we we it wasn't even rescheduled it was
just we just
we don't know what happened we don't
know what happened to him but uh my
interview with
vaush uh did happen let me just very
very briefly
i'll play just a hard-hitting moment of
my interview with vaush this goes live
at uh no it's not vaush i know it's vosh
vosh destiny [ __ ] iii
this will be going live in about three
hours on my youtube channel okay just
take a listen to this reasonable again
or at least more
standard that's uh i mean that that's
that's
we we agree we definitely are agreeing
on more than i imagined
maybe this is the where we could end it
do you think an
open-faced omelette is a pizza where do
you come down on that
i am uh i am a um culinary and
linguistic descriptivist i think that if
you want to call it a pizza you have to
and i will respect your right to do so
so an open face omelette you're fine
calling a pizza absolutely
wow 100 that's huge that's huge and if
you put a tortilla under it then it's
absolutely a pizza right
oh oh i mean that just i mean that nails
at home not that it needed
that affirmation but anyway so that the
full interview will be live at 6 45 p.m
eastern time and
most of it is about other things uh
we talk about socialism social democracy
and um all of that uh all of that
different stuff
i do want to let you know that we've
enabled nightbot on both youtube and
twitch
we're adding commands we are adding
elements and nightbot is going to be
babysitting the chat
in addition to a number of different um
a number of different moderators so
that's very very exciting
um dan alley has a very important
message via twitch i'm sorry via youtube
super chat and this is a beautiful
moment to send a super chat
david this is just a reminder to the
audience we can still donate to the
georgia senate race which is desperately
needed if we want actual change
100 andrew yang is moving to
georgia um and at least temporarily i
guess
to help with those races really really
important stuff going on
in uh in georgia and i encourage
everybody to get involved we will be
getting involved as well
um emilio says check your instagram
direct messages yeah i mean
you should see what they look like i
just can't my instagram direct messages
are
are worthless at this point in time um
david i heard about it on another left
live stream does the facebook demonetize
give you pause for future segments
oh i'm not exactly sure what you mean
but listen to this
so the other day on facebook
on all of our platforms i talked about
i talked about the fact that steve
bannon
called for the beheading of dr anthony
fauci okay
i and obviously i said that that's crazy
we got 100 demonetized on facebook our
facebook revenue went to zero and
facebook actually became an important
part of our revenue i think lately
facebook's been about 17 18
of our revenue on facebook so it's a
significant amount
we are demonetized on facebook because i
said hey
steve bannon said this crazy thing okay
look at this
look at this garbage zuckerberg defends
not suspending bannon facebook
uh chief executive mark zuckerberg
told an all staff meeting on thursday
that former trump white house adviser
steve bannon
had not violated enough of the company's
policies to justify his suspension
when he urged the beheading of two
senior u.s officials
i i really need people to understand
this what steve bannon
said was so vile
okay so depraved so disgusting
that my mere mention of it in the
context of saying
it was bad for him to say that got me
demonetized
but the guy who actually said this stuff
hasn't done enough to get banned yet
you understand um
okay yeah i guess i could go on for
about an hour on this but i'm not going
to
what the hell is that one two three four
five
what on earth oh there's audio coming
through the white house fee okay
morrigan
geez that surprised me um
anyway so that's that's pretty vile and
this is why you know when i
i know it's almost become a joke and i
do have a joke about it to play for you
guys in a moment
we joke around about oh we depend on
memberships and stuff
we just lost almost 20 percent of our
revenue because i mentioned steve bannon
saying something bannon's fine but we
lost you know 17 18 percent of our
revenue it's it's absolutely disgusting
i have a few funny things for you guys
though
uh producer pat this is this is
brilliant
trump's voter fraud line i guess was
just shut down because it was getting
trolled too much
but just before it got shut down
producer pat
called the voter fraud line and he
actually got through to someone
and he reported me david parkman
for vote voting multiple times and he
actually was able to crowbar in
our possibly illegal membership
discounts this
is beautifully executed as many of you
know in non-corona times i go to to las
vegas twice a year for a conference and
you know whatever anyway so producer pat
was able to
reference our possibly illegal
membership discounts
my often mispronounced name as parkman
as well as my trips to las vegas into
this perfect phone call take a listen to
this let me just get it give me a moment
to get it set up
okay hold on pause let me bring it over
whoa hold on a second it'll just take me
like a moment to do this
oh my god that's the wrong video hold on
holy crap everything's going wrong here
let me reopen it open with
vlc
hold on pause let me bring it in here
okay good i'm just going to shrink it
i i do think you guys are really going
to like this this is pretty good stuff
uh all right so this is producer pat
okay calling the voter fraud
line to report me take a listen to this
hello yes i would like to report voter
hold on can you guys even hear that
was that could you guys hear that that's
weird i didn't see it coming up on my uh
you could oh okay okay okay i'm sorry
here we go
hello yes i would like to report voter
fraud today
sure what's your experience um well
there's a certain david parkman
who i know to have voted in nevada
um three times at least
okay and what county is that in clark
county
he goes there uh twice a year for a
conference and also he happens to be
giving out
um borderline illegal membership
discounts
uh like 50 off 60 off 70 percent off
and i'm worried that that could be
sacrificing the integrity of the
election
okay and what was your name my name is
mcdonald mcdonald it's like mclovin
just mcdonald okay well i'll send this
on your behalf
um thanks so much macdonald is reporting
50 60 and even 70 percent off
uh just absolutely perfect i don't know
how he's not laughing yeah so that
that's
if i don't know if i've ever seen as
perfect a phone call let me just
re-listen one more time to the discount
part because that's just perfect
in clark county he goes there uh twice a
year for a um
conference and also he happens to be
giving out um
borderline illegal membership discounts
uh
like 50 off 60 off 70 off and
i'm worried that that could be
sacrificing the integrity of the
election
okay and what was your name my name is
mcdonald no i'm i'm guessing pat didn't
plan on mcdonald up front
like if he had planned like he could
have anticipated being asked his name
and he could have come up with something
else i'm guessing mcdonald was spur of
the moment
okay well i'll send this on your behalf
um thanks so much for
calling imagine that we were able to get
pat
on um like lou dobbs show
saying he's one of the whistleblowers
and imagine if we could get him on fox
because fox news has actually gotten
trolled before by
you know fake once they interviewed this
guy who i later interviewed who was like
yeah i voted obama in 2012 but then i
went trump and it was totally made up
and he trolled fox and it was perfect
imagine if we got
pat on fox and he said uh i saw david
david pakman
offering 50 60 and even 70 off
memberships it would really be stunning
so that's
excellent i mean just excellent
excellent work by pat
um okay one other video to play for you
we did get video of a cat that i guess i
don't you
i'm not really a cat behaviorist but you
guys tell me
does it look like this cat is enjoying
watching me
or doesn't like me because i guess the
cat does this every time
that i'm on tv take a look it is not
common that in the united states after
an election is done
after the votes are in uh showing
that there is an irreversible victory by
one candidate
like i just don't know i know about dog
behavior but i don't know about cat
behavior does that mean the cat likes me
most people are saying the cat does like
me based on that
a few people saying the cat is angry
with me on this basis
i don't again i just don't know enough
about cats to be able to say but that's
that's a nice video that i got as well
okay let me get caught up as far as new
member numbers
11 more people have signed up on my
website which puts us
at 24 and then over on twitch
we got eight more which puts us at
32. we're standing by for donald trump's
first public appearance
since claiming victory during a bizarre
press conference i think it was last
wednesday or maybe last thursday so
we're going to be hearing from donald
trump at the top of the hour
let me get to some of these super chats
roy brown says another fiver for
mcdonald's straight
face pair says the cat wants a hug
will says if trump's understanding of
legal votes is so skewed from its legal
meaning
do you think similar skewed views are
seen toward legal immigration by trump
and his followers and how dangerous is
this thinking
of course they don't understand any of
what's going on that's that there's no
doubt about that
no doubt about it and it's extremely
dangerous
why are you dismissing the testimony
from the woman who saw the vans
so quickly i'm gonna assume that that's
a joke steve and if it's not a joke this
is probably not the right channel for
you but i'm gonna i'm going to
imagine that that is not a serious uh
not a serious question
um i want to play for you and read a few
emails from you that have come in
if you follow me on instagram and you
really should
if you were following me on instagram
you would have seen
the very strong retweet from gabrielle
union
but you also would have seen this email
i got this morning
this is from navarro who wrote to me and
said
i know if you put your bias-ness aside
okay whoa whoa whoa very good if you put
your biases aside you can see a miles
away the election was rigged
but you biden loved ducks tobias are
stupid to see
all those riots with antifa was biden's
boogie clan to discredit president
trump your show is as fake as cnn fake
news
nobody gives an f what you think about
the election
report real news you the democrat
communist liberal party can suck biden
okay
in his basement until his right balls
get jealous
report something real like zuckerberg
isn't a real human or something like
that and stop hate
preach honesty and unity jackass instead
of trying to fool the people watching
your bs show i've been told a lot of
people's kids watch the stream so i'm
trying to keep it a little cleaner
so that's an email i received um and if
you follow me on instagram you would be
very much aware of that i also have a
couple of voicemails to
play for you i have not yet screened
these but these seem to be more new
characters from this guy troy york
uh here is his character dave berksen
take a listen to this
oh wait hold on i have to unmute unmute
take a listen to this
hey david hackman hey dave berksen here
hey uh you had a meme on your youtube
site
uh with a spaceman pointing a gun behind
another spaceman talking about
snowflakes with the maga hats
maga hot i just want to let you know i
reported that to youtube that's
promoting political terrorism
um against individuals so i don't know
if you'll get word on it but i just want
to let you know hey
we won't now reported it that's me
yeah so that's troy york then troy york
leaving another
voicemail under the fake name woody
underwood
hello david pakman this is woody
underwood um
i'm just wondering on the republican uh
point of view
um you know it sounds like my show's
playing in the background also or in
this country they have
more than one party and i don't
understand why
i hear people talking anyway so that one
goes on for three minutes and then this
i think this is his fake italian
character this guy
he calls in with a fake hispanic
character named and this is how he
pronounces it ramon ramos
he has a fake black character named
jamal jenkins
and i believe i'm looking at the
transcript i think this is a fake
italian character called
i'm looking at the transcript it says
jacobi genovese
but i'm not sure let's see how he
actually says it yes uh david pakman
this is jacoby genovese yeah
and uh i'm just wondering uh
everywhere i go i see people wear masks
and like uh
masks are everywhere i travel throughout
the midwest
uh with my business
and basically everyone's wearing masks
so the question i i
want to ponder to you is why are kovit
rates
still going up when everyone that i see
is wearing a [ __ ] mask
okay so um this is a really funny story
so troy york has been calling into the
show for
years and he calls in with these
different characters and he always calls
from a blocked number he blocks his
number
i've never i haven't mentioned this
before last week
troy york forgot to block his number
and we now know exactly who he is we
know exactly where he lives and
obviously we're not going to dox this
guy but it's just so funny because for
five
six years this guy's been calling from a
blocked number
and i guess he just forgot one time and
now we know exactly who this guy
is and um
you know it's just so so funny um
okay so anyway that's what we've got
going as far as
voicemails go um
we're waiting for donald trump i would
be shocked if he takes questions but
maybe maybe he will if you're just
joining us
please make sure if you're one of the 73
000 people watching on youtube right now
make sure to hit that subscribe button
so you'll be notified in the future when
we go live
we will be streaming georgia senate
debates we will be streaming
uh biden's inauguration we will be
streaming
biden events kamala harris events we
will be streaming dr
fauci events you know make sure you're
following us subscribe
it's free on youtube follow us if you're
watching of course on twitch make sure
to give us a like if you're watching on
facebook all very very important
i do have a couple of new songs to play
for you guys i'll just get these out of
the way and then i'll be almost caught
up
on everything i had for you guys um here
is
a oh oh here is my georgia okay i was
looking for
joe biden becomes the first democrat to
win georgia in 28 years
we already talked about it i couldn't
find the article before
here is a new exclusive song from
michael carlucci
of the paula white fiasco
take a listen to this
strike and strike and strike and strike
and strike and strike and strike and
strike this is sort of like an easily
easy listening type thing
until you have victory for every enemy
that is aligned it can strike and strike
and strike and strike and strike
more in the term in the mood of like 90s
tony braxton for example
strike and strike and strike and strike
until you have victory
for every enemy that is aligned against
you strike and strike and strike and
strike and strike and strike and strike
and stand strike
until you have victory for every enemy
that is aligned against you
let there be that
[Music]
you know it's windy as hell out here
this room is so hot in here maybe i'll
start to believe it myself and strike
and strike and strike and strike and
strike and strike and strike and strike
i hear a sound i'm abundant
number one i'm in love and you're in
love we're all in love together and i'm
in the white house and i was lonely
people
falling talking sending things to us you
turn into there's kovitkovic
i hear the sound of abundance of rain
don't give me the umbrella
i will be president for many
many many many years to come
well i can't in good countenance
continue showing you this
the neil cavuto at the end is perfect
okay so we've got that
then here is a we're still waiting for
donald trump
we're gonna be fine if you're just
joining us we're just you know enjoying
uh
enjoying some new music this is a
re-imagination of the david pakman show
theme
with a number of different musical
elements i think you'll like this one
this one gets really good
[Music]
here's something interesting today's
episode is sponsored by
[Music]
we have so much to cover today that i
will not waste
any time
[Music]
so anyway that's that's a pretty hot
track what i would really like to do
actually
is to get the internet's busiest music
nerd anthony fantano
to review all of these different songs i
think it would be a really interesting
thing like if he took it seriously and
did real reviews of these
songs even if they got bad reviews i
think that that would be a pretty funny
crossover
and then just a couple of others here um
this is this is called highly triggered
individual this is the latest track from
jethro bradley
should i play this this is one of the
most vile callers we have
take a listen to that i have not
pre-screened this so i let me just warn
you
this may not be suitable for children
for children
now that your uh your hero is there are
you going to sit there in your little
kimono
and wear your little hat right
because it's going to be called no free
speech
red chinese communist speech
but you can't have pork because you
might offend the ayatollahs
after all you're gonna love this too
you're gonna make a bomb and i hope they
drop it right on your freaking ass
but you can't have pork you but you
can't have pork
right but you can't have pork
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway so that one's really good and
then i think i have time for just one
more song this is the paula white is
winning track in the name of jesus from
south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here
they're coming here from africa
i hear the sound of victory
yeah this will get us ready for trump
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
so that that actually of all of these
songs that we've gotten that may be my
favorite one
so we're watching every single one of
these different streams
whoa and we are going to um we're
going to be seeing donald trump very
very soon so all right i got through
everything
it's really really good stuff and we've
got to figure out uh what uh what to do
with those
as we wait for donald trump let me issue
my one
i'm reducing my membership hard sell to
only one per stream
here's the bottom line all these
different platforms are on
every once in a while they totally
demonetize us we've gotten banned from
twitch before
by cnn we've gotten demonetized on
youtube to the tune of 98
we're currently demonetized on facebook
to the tune of 100
because i mentioned something steve
bannon said okay so
the way that we protect ourselves from
that is we just go directly to the
audience
you can go to joinpakman.com i have this
coupon code fresh start
why is it fresh start you guys
understand why i'm sure
we had an election last week joe biden
won we're taking a fresh start
that's it it's very very simple join
pakman.com
coupon code fresh start it saves you 70
percent
i know i've already been reported to the
the trump uh
what's it called the trump fraud line
for these discounts i'm going to
continue offering them until they take
me out in handcuffs okay so that's the
coupon code
and we have a modest goal of 100 we're
at 32
it takes mere seconds to sign up and you
of course get access to the bonus show
today's bonus show contains more crank
calls to the trump voter fraud line by
producer pat so there's really really
good stuff
um happening on the bonus show and i
encourage
literally everyone i mean listen if half
of one percent of the people watching
right now grab a membership
that's 400 memberships
okay half of one percent of everybody
watching right now because we do have
what is the 6573
square root derivative second derivative
sine cosine
we have 77 000 people watching right now
across the various platforms we are on
so this these are these are some pretty
serious numbers at this point in time
i see a lot of people asking whether
donald trump might end up conceding uh
during this
um oh hold on a second should we i think
we have to ban hammer a few people
we accept right wingers in all of our
chats but we're not going to just accept
you know hate speech and and you know
vile personal attacks so we've got some
ban hammers being dropped
um i don't think trump's going to
concede no i doubt i doubt trump will
even take questions i would be shocked
if trump took questions
reports are that he's simply humiliated
and that's why he's not um
essentially leaving uh being seen in
public other than when he did a wreath
laying
on veterans day uh i do not believe that
he will concede here
okay other super chats that are coming
in
um let's see here what do we have
um what do we have what do we have
jr says keep seeing what about death's
cause from suicide drug overdose due to
lockdowns from
maga heads would like to see deep dive
on this talking point that's a fit
that's a reasonable idea
wendy asking what trump is going to talk
about today well officially this is
about operation work speed warp speed
and vaccines
so my sense is that trump will be
taking credit for coronavirus vaccines
that are not yet out
if he took questions obviously every
question is going to be about
is he going to concede does he accept
that he lost but officially this is
about
vaccination um
sad girl says my mom is watching this hi
mom love you what a nice message
lou says your top 10 list of highest
viewed videos are mostly from six seven
eight years ago why have your
most recent videos failed to go viral
despite many more subs
so what so what actually matters is
views per time
and so we actually had more million view
videos
in 2020 than any other year
when a video has been out for seven
years it's been having it's had seven
years to accumulate views you understand
what i'm saying
when a video has only been out for a
month or two months or three months
the views per day are dramatically
higher
yeah exactly as microphages is pointing
out
because the videos haven't been out for
eight years yet yeah exactly it's a very
very silly question
um and uh i would even call it a nasty
question
which i love i mean i love i love
fielding nasty questions all day
but it's a pretty nasty question um
anita recounts i like that says maybe
trump should move to oregon
in january i think he could benefit from
those psychedelics
i see a lot of people asking how to get
their super chat on the screen
um send a super chat use the dollar sign
if you're watching on youtube at the
bottom of the chat window
mr neil is asking where can i get that
music here's what i would like to do
i don't know how to do this but i want
to go to all of the different people
that have made these songs you know
jethro bradley and dj physic
joseph woodward who has made a bunch of
different songs i want to go to all of
them and say
are you up for us putting together an
album um and putting it on spotify
and i don't know what it would be called
exactly we would need a name
for for the album but i want to put the
entire thing together on spotify so that
all of these songs are available to you
guys i think that would be great
and then once we do that i would love to
have anthony fantano review the songs i
think that there's a lot here
a thousand mics is an idea that's being
proposed for the album name
malarkey is another idea
um yeah i'm i'm open to different ideas
love songs for a new age yeah i don't
know if that would be
maybe just david pakman show greatest
hits volume one i don't know
elements of music actually i like that
that's maybe the best one so far
but that's my idea i would love to do
something like that
i think it would be really great uh
let's see jett says that the cat in the
video i played
is playing with the buttons on my shirt
that maybe
that may be many many super chats
coming in julian says do you think
recordings of trump phone calls with
foreign leaders will be investigated
i bet there's many more like the phone
call to ukraine well the ukraine phone
call was a perfect phone call from what
i recall
i don't know the dude says has anyone
done a tracking of the spikes
of coronavirus in relation to the trump
rallies
i find it hard to believe they don't
mirror each other yeah so
one study from stanford looked at just
18
specific rallies and found that those
led to 30
000 cases and 700 deaths that they
know about so trump did far more than 18
rallies so
my my estimate would be that a few
thousand deaths a couple thousand
fifteen hundred to three thousand deaths
could be traced to trump
rallies now of course a lot of those uh
deaths were not people that went to the
rallies
they were people that later got the
virus from those who went to the rally
et cetera et cetera i'm sure you guys
understand
um sort of that uh that's that's how
that works
okay i have an update on subscriber
numbers
we just got 61 more website subscribers
which from 32 puts us at 93
we're also counting twitch subs and i
have
13 more on twitch which puts us at 106.
let's go for 306 why because that's the
number of electoral votes that joe biden
now has
which is a uh which is a great number
people on twitch asking me about the the
samuel alito video from today i haven't
watched the entire video i watched the
first 30 seconds just to see what it was
all about then i'll watch the rest of it
for monday
um i was shocked by samuel alito's
physical appearance i
i didn't even recognize him i thought it
was someone introducing alito i don't
know if any of you guys
experienced that but i had an image of
alito in my head that is dramatically
different
and i don't know if he's just aged
significantly i barely recognize the guy
it was very strange
i uh i surprised myself actually
okay what is your thought on the cyber
security experts that were asked to
resign by
force and replaced with stooges of trump
i believe that that is just trump
getting
people he's been wanting to fire for a
while out of the way
i don't think that that is part of any
kind of big plan to do anything
not because trump would it be morally
opposed
trump's not shown that he's even
remotely organized enough to do
something like that
um and that's why i don't think it is
anything more tyler cobb says thanks for
everything i think you should rename the
show the david
the pacman ultra show could up your
anime viewers
also do you watch anime the only thing i
so okay i've read
akira and i've watched spirited away
that's all i've ever seen or read from
as far from the standpoint of manga
and uh anime some people call it anime
i i call it on anime the sound
of winning is an interesting name for
that album that's i like that idea
david say democrats do take the senate
what could we expect in terms of health
care public option or is that too
optimistic
listen i think that that's the let's get
the senate and then we will discuss it
that's the starting point first let's
get the senate
i'm being told that prompt tweeted let's
see what he said
we'll be having a press conference from
the rose garden in 15 minutes he tweeted
that seven minutes ago okay 15 minus
seven
members you know 15 minus seven coming
through
20 of that eight minutes from now we
should be seeing donald trump
out and uh so we've got eight minutes to
talk about
a few other things with you guys
um what am i watching or
reading right now let's see reading
i'm in the middle of kim stanley
robinson's california trilogy
the first one is i would call it almost
a perfect book
and um getting into the second one
just finished a little bit of uh
which one i believe it's locked doors
i've been reading
i've been reading all of blake crouch's
work we had him on the show
not that long ago and we talked about um
i think it was dark matter he wrote
recursion which is
excellent recursion is just awesome
and i've just been reading some of his
older stuff and as far as non-fiction
um i'm reading michael pollan's in
defense of food which is not new i just
haven't read it for a while
and watching i've just watched uh
two okay so for non-fiction there's this
great four-episode series on netflix a
true crime series from argentina
called the death i believe it's called
in english the death of maria marta it's
about a case
a murder from the year 2001 in argentina
really really good
and non-fiction on netflix i've been
watching four seasons in havana which is
a cuban
sort of anthology series the the four
episodes they're each 90 minutes long
they're all related
with the same characters but you could
watch them in any order and
um that is they're based on
stories by the great cuban author
leonardo paluta
excellent excellent author and a four
it's not four seasons landscaping
importantly it's uh four seasons in
havana and it is
excellent excellent not for children
aggressive
okay very very aggressive not for
children
uh that's what i'm that's what i've got
going right now
no not paluda
okay good all right updated okay people
are saying i signed up and you didn't
thank me david
everybody's mad okay we're at 102
that's plus 41 41 website members puts
us at 147
and thanks to some really strong gifted
subs from
i'm inconsolable we're at 25
36 on twitch which is 14
161. yeah so recently
david chadman and spudnik have been
gifting a lot of subs on twitch
but they still can't even come close to
the 435
subs that i'm inconsolable has gifted on
twitch just not even remotely close
and it's no insult to them it's just
shocking the number of gifted subs from
uh
from i'm inconsolable which is which is
crazy it's absolutely crazy
okay um that was a big diversion i
understand let me get to a couple of
other super chats
uh mary says obviously kovid will be the
focus do you think biden will quickly
overturn trump's executive orders like
the muslim ban muslim ban is on the list
of biden's day one executive orders
help me out chat but um what i believe
is currently on biden's day one
executive orders
is muslim ban uh
overturning getting back in the who
what well trump only partially left so
it really means
stop leaving um back in the w.h.o
overturn muslim ban um get back in paris
climate
end the military trans ban what else is
on day one executive orders
yeah i mentioned paris agreement um
maybe deal with some of the uh oh undo
some of trump's loosening of uh
environmental regulations yes that's
there as well
and daca daca that's right yeah restart
the dreamer program as well
um i think those are all the things that
so far
were on the day one list
if i recall correctly yeah a lot of epa
environmental stuff which i think will
be really
really important to do jeremiah suggests
an album name
bigly strongly and like you've never
seen before i actually
think just bigly strongly would be
interesting
if anybody knows how to put an album on
spotify
or has a contact that could help or
you know how to use google and you can
send me a link to how to do it any of
the above
please let me know because i i'm going
to reach out to all of our different
composers and see if we can do a 2020
album maybe called bigly strongly i like
that idea a lot
oh there's a rap artist named bigly
strongly
we don't want to we don't want to i
wouldn't want to do that
um you just put it on spotify oh okay
good all right but then i'll just do it
very good other super chats coming in
david do you think trump will pardon
himself from what i've been reading he
can't do that
um hilarious that ted cruz would support
trump's fraud claims when trump accused
ted
cruz of fraud in 2016. well trump also
said ted cruz's wife is ugly
um so it's shocking that these people
have come back anyway
did anyone notice the cat was playing
with the mouse icon
that i didn't see thomas says birthday
shout out to my fiance
happy birthday danielle yes absolutely
very happy birthday to danielle hope
that
everybody's doing well in the world of
thomas and danielle
some twitch messages coming in keep up
the good stuff thank you
and oh i guess that's the only one oh
wondering what you thought of oh this is
pink and blonde asking what did i think
of good economics for hard times
esther duflo is the reason i'm pursuing
a phd in economics we need more women in
research positions her contributions are
inspiring
fantastic book i'm trying to get either
either of the authors this is a married
couple abhijit banerjee
and esther duflo who wrote the book good
economics for hard times
fantastic book i recommend it we're
going to try to get one of them on the
show
and fantastic book absolutely
fantastic book can't beat it
many asians hold on what was that
uh i missed that where did it go
many many asian and chinese americans
supported trump for his stance on the
ccp do you think
biden will have a good strategy when it
comes to china oh my god is that dr
burks
is burke's back that's wild
i think biden biden knows a thousand
times
more about china than trump does and i
think biden's going to be fine on china
absolutely fine on china david check
trump's twitter says kelsey
we did i'm guessing that was sent
after i checked it or before i did but
we'll be having a press conference
in 15 minutes that was 15 minutes ago so
i think we're going to see trump very
very soon here
um i'm happy i found this channel
a very nasty mixtape by pacman and
friends that's not a bad idea for the
album
i like that do i think skin snatcher
mcconnell will change
hosts this administration this current
one is starting to molt
some doctors wrote to me and i i don't
want to spread anything
unconfirmed but doctors wrote to me and
they said
mitch mcconnell really didn't look good
with his purple hands that it was like
that it was it could be something very
serious they're not saying anything i
don't think it makes sense to speculate
beyond that but
i think it would be interesting to know
if the senate majority leader
is very ill um is that oh dear god is
that pence
oh they're bringing out the cavalry guys
so this could be pretty weaponized
we'll have to wait and see and they're
all remaining standing no they're
sitting now
yeah any moment now we're expecting to
hear from donald trump
if you are just joining us in all
seriousness if you're watching on
youtube
please do hit the subscribe button we
in the last 28 days we brought in 82 000
new youtube subscribers
they seem like cartoonish numbers we are
82
000 subscribers bigger today than we
were 28 days ago
we've never had a 28 day period like
this
let's keep it going we also have never
had a better 30 days
on twitch than the last month um
so just thank you to everybody and my
goal is
let's get in a good position for the new
year when we might actually have an
opportunity to make some things
happen uh with trump out it's going to
be pretty uh pretty pretty spicy stuff
other super chats call it the david
trackman show hmm
chakaseki says best anime is legends of
the galactic heroes a truly phenomenal
show about political intrigue demagogues
and difficulty of sustaining democracy
nice asking about the npvic
i'm in favor of it i probably have five
or ten clips on youtube about about it
so definitely check
check those out i should watch other
miyazaki movies they're all masterpieces
yeah
they i really should how's the weather
in new england
it's uh rainy and chilly
rainy and chilly today your channel has
twice the amount of viewers of the
official white house channel is that
true let's see
we have 84th we might actually hit our
all-time record for live
viewers today i don't think we've ever
gotten past 86
000 on youtube we're at 84 right now the
trump
white house channel has 36 000 viewers
on youtube
we have 84 000. that's insane that's
almost three times the the audience of
trump that's crazy
all right here he is folks let's uh
could be one of the last times we see
him
could be leaving the white house for
good and thanksgiving christmas who
knows
thank you very much thank you
beautiful out here this time of year
in the past nine months my
administration has initiated the
single greatest mobilization in u.s
history pioneering developing and
manufacturing therapies and vaccines
in record time numbers like nobody's
seen before
nothing's happening medical breakthrough
of this scope and magnitude has ever
been
achieved this rapidly this quickly and
we're very proud of it and had
tremendous help from the military
generals admirals and many of the great
people at the white house
operation warp speed is unequaled
and unrivaled anywhere in the world and
leaders of other countries have called
me to congratulate
us on what we've been able to do they
have not dude come on
many countries with their ventilators
and all of the problems they were still
telling that like to
congratulate everyone involved in this
effort it's been an incredible effort
as a result of operation warp speed
pfizer announced on monday that it's
china pfizer didn't take money from
operations
percent effective this far exceeds any
and all
experts they didn't take money from that
they get to
and we have others coming which we think
will be at equal level maybe
more of that's possible in july my
administration reached an agreement with
pfizer to provide
1.95 billion dollars to support the mass
manufacturing and distribution of 100
million
said they took none of his money the
option to purchase a total of 600
million doses shortly thereafter
they'll sell you vaccines sure for the
vaccine to be provided by pfizer
free of charge that's a different story
said it wasn't part of warp speed but
that turned out to be a
unfortunate misrepresentation
that's why we gave them the 1.95 million
billion dollars and
an agreement to buy vaccines in the
future is not participating that these
are different things
an emergency use authorization which
should be coming down
extremely soon and my administration
will then coordinate
the distribution of the vaccine and uh
it will be approved i think again it
will be approved very very
quickly we hope the average development
timeline for
the vaccine including clinical tests and
manufacturing can take 8 to 12 years
through operation warp speed we're doing
it in less than one year
if you had a different administration
with different people
what we've done would have taken in my
opinion three four
five he's acting like he hasn't lost the
fda forever
bizarre this is five times faster than
the fastest prior vaccine development in
history
five times faster say it again five
times faster
nobody can believe it actually three
other vaccines are also in the final
stages of trial
they'll arrive within a few weeks and
they will also be
mass-produced and the delivery will be
very rapid i'll believe it when fouchy
says it you know
the vaccine will be distributed to
front-line workers the elderly and
high-risk americans immediately
it will be very a matter of weeks get
out very
very much ahead of schedule any schedule
that
i said we're going to be far ahead of
that
why we know that this virus primarily
targets older populations and those
with underlying health conditions well
over 99.98
of those under the age of 50 make a full
and quick recovery by giving the vaccine
to high-risk individuals right away will
dramatically reduce
hospitalizations and deaths he does seem
to be acting like he'll be president
when this stuff will go on but
a lot of the case levels are high
because of the fact that
uh we have the best testing program
anywhere in the world we've developed
the most and the best tests and we test
far more than any other country so it
shows obviously
more cases by vaccinating the elderly
and the high risk we will
effectively end this phase of the
pandemic and allow seniors to reclaim
their
golden years the golden years of their
lives which is so incredible
and it's about time that they can have
those golden years again this process is
starting
right away millions of doses will soon
be going out the door
he's been saying that for a year we're
already waiting for that final approval
as soon as april the vaccine will be
available to the entire general
population
april with the exception of places like
new york state
where for political reasons the governor
uh decided they say and you know i don't
think it's good politically i think it's
very bad from a health standpoint but
uh he wants to take his time on the
vaccine he doesn't
trust where the vaccine is coming from
these are coming from the greatest
companies anywhere in the world greatest
labs in the world but he doesn't trust
the fact that it's this white house this
administration so
we won't be delivering it to new york
until we have authorization to do so and
that pains me to say that this is a very
successful
amazing vaccine at 90 percent and more
but so the governor governor cuomo will
have to let us know when he's ready for
it otherwise
we we can't we can't be delivering it to
a state
that won't be giving it to its people
immediately people and i know many i
know the people of new york very well i
know they want it
so the governor will let us know when
he's ready he's had some very bad
uh editorials doesn't sound like a
concession speech guys
statement and what's happened with
respect to nursing homes and his
handling of
nursing homes and i hope he doesn't
handle this as badly as he's handled the
nursing homes
but we're ready to provide as soon as
they let us know that they'll actually
use it and again it's a very safe and
and a great vaccine already we have
among the lowest case fatality rates
our country anywhere in the world the
entire world
it's like he lost an election he's still
telling the exact same lies countries
as far as therapeutics are concerned my
administration's also made critical
investments and therapies that have
helped reduce the mortality rate by 85
that's to me one of the most exciting
things it's incredible some of the
really exciting
viruses others that have come out and
have really helped people
eighty-five percent last month the fda
approved remdessevier
and we've secured enough room to severe
to treat eight hundred and fifty
thousand
patients my administration finalizes we
figure out from death severe is not
quite so good
to purchase the first doses of their
antibody
therapy which shows amazing results
this treatment will be available
completely free of cost to patients 5
000 units have already been shipped
and many more going out the door as we
speak were also reached an agreement
with
astrazeneca for the large-scale
manufacturing of their antibody
treatment
which is excellent we expect to issue
emergency use authorizations for a
number of additional treatments
in the near future tremendous promise
but remember the 85 percent number
that's an incredible
right remember that lie you have some
tremendously promising
don't forget it drugs online and ready
to come out
we have ensured that our frontline
workers have all the tools they need
my administration has invoked the
defense production act and related
authorities over 100 times
and have made a historic investment into
our industrial base
all states that requested ppe from the
federal government have received the ppe
almost immediately upon request every
american who needed a ventilator has had
access to a ventilator think of that
very complicated piece of equipment very
expensive
and we haven't had one person in this
whole country that
has requested or needed a ventilator
that hasn't had it
every single request has been
immediately filled this place is now
out of pbe great job and now we're
helping the rest of the world with
ventilators because it's a very hard
thing
we're producing them thousands of
thousands of ventilators a month
the federal government has 22 000 beds
immediately available for states and
jurisdictions that need additional
capacity
but we think that it's going to start
going down possibly
very quickly we'll see what happens but
with the vaccine it'll you'll see
numbers uh going down within a matter of
months and they'll go down very rapidly
as we continue to combat the virus our
economy
is rebounding far beyond any
expectations i see the stock market's up
almost 400 points today again and
it's ready to break the all-time record
our jobs records are
incredible the job numbers are
incredible do you think he believes this
stuff created over 13 million jobs and
slashed the unemployment rate
by more than half last quarter we
witnessed the fastest economic growth
ever recorded in the history of our
country
33.1 percent it's a number that is more
than double
our highest that was in 1952 and we've
more than doubled that the united states
experienced the smallest economic
contraction
and the most rapid economic recovery of
any major western nation
we went down less and we went up more
which is quite a combination of facts
that's a serious combination americans
have gone back to work into school we
continue to
spare no expense to protect the elderly
and the vulnerable
yeah but did you win some estimates a
national lockdown costs 50 billion
dollars a day
and hundreds of thousands of jobs every
single day
ideally we won't go to a lockdown i will
not go
this administration will not be going to
hopefully the
the uh whatever happens in the future
who knows which administration will be i
guess time will tell but you guys see
that right i can tell you this
administration will not go to a lockdown
whatever happens be necessity lock down
we will cease
lives and they cost he almost
accidentally conceded there
can not be you've got to remember cannot
be worse than the problem itself and
i've said it many times
and uh when you look at what happens
during a lockdown i just
say it very loudly it's horrible what
happens with drugs alcohol
depression loss of jobs business
closures
it's a terrible thing so this
administration will not go
under any circumstances will not go to a
lockdown but we'll be very vigilant very
careful
yeah we understand the disease it's a
it's a complicated disease but we
understand it very well
we ask all americans to remain vigilant
especially
as the weather gets colder and it
becomes more difficult to go
outside and to have outside gatherings
and with that i just want to ask
some very talented people to come up and
say a few words
general purna and dr slowy have been
incredible uh the general is really
getting started right now but he's
really what we don't know and what
people don't know he started
putting this all together six months ago
and you're going to see some real action
so general maybe you'll start it off
and then doctor you'll go right after
that thank you very much and then we're
going to
finish it off with mike pence okay thank
you please
so uh not taking questions very clearly
by the way we are at 100 000 live
viewers on youtube
we have never hit 100k before strong
enable
and accelerate the development of
vaccines and therapeutic to help control
the kovind 19 pandemic
and save lives on may 15
almost six months ago to the day we
stated the goal of the operation which
was to have
vaccines and therapeutics available and
approved for use in the us population
by the end of the year 2020. we said
then that
while very challenging the goal was
credible and therefore
was worth trying with the best
our best to achieve it this is my only
interruption
it's insane that the vaccine that's
close to approval
was starting to be developed in germany
in january before this guy was ever
brought on
before trump even accepted there would
be a single case in the united states
these are delusions you are being
presented here
if i look at the vaccine side we've
selected a portfolio of six
vaccines using three different platform
technologies and we elected to have two
vaccines from each
platform technology first platform
is what's called messenger rna and two
vaccines using that platform
were uh in the portfolio one by pfizer
and one by uh moderna the second
platform is using
uh what's called live viral vectors and
we had one vaccine from j and j
and one vaccine from asteroids and
zenica in partnership with oxford
university and the third platform
was the recombinant protein platform
with one vaccines from a biotech company
here in the u.s called novovax
and another one from a partnership
between sanofi and glaxosmithkline
these vaccines are now six vaccines are
all in
the clinical development stages and four
of them
are in phase three trials and of the
four that are in phase three trials
two have effectively completed
enrollment in the phase iii trial
and one of the two has announced on
monday to
i think uh thrilling information that
they had 90 percent efficacy that was
the pfizer vaccine
demonstrating that vaccination is
possible against
kovite 19 that the kind of choices we
have made in terms of the antigen
selected
was effective and
made us optimistic that other vaccine
may also be effective on wednesday the
same week
just this wednesday modern the other
company with the vaccine using
similar platform technology messenger
rna announces they have
achieved the number of cases in their
trial to allow for
first interim analysis and i would
expect
that shortly probably next week we may
hear
what i hope to be another very good
information regarding
unification's vaccine the two other
vaccines
that are in phase 3 trial that are using
the live vector
platform the jnj vaccine and the
astrozenica vaccine
have recruited already a few thousand
subjects in their
uh trials i would like to take this
opportunity to invite as many americans
as possible who would like to volunteer
to participate in this there you go
as that's the only way we are able to
it's an opportunity
a demonstration of the safety and the
efficacy of these vaccines
the last two vaccines the protein
recombinant protein vaccines
are planned to start their phase 3
trials within the next
few weeks and while we
are developing this vaccine we haven't
only looked at the clinical development
of course in partnership with the
companies that are the sponsors for the
vaccine we also invested
very significantly in the manufacturing
of this vaccine in such a way as to when
we have the clinical
efficacy demonstration with these
vaccines
we would also have vaccine doses to be
able to immunize
the us population where's fauci so
the two vaccines that are completing
their phase 3 trial
are likely to be filing their
files with the fda
for a potential emergency use
authorization within the next few weeks
and hopefully if approved they could be
used for immunization in the us
population in the month of december
and we have we plan to have enough
vaccine
doses available for use in the u.s
population
to immunize about 20 million individuals
in the month of december
and another 25 to 30 million
per month on an ongoing basis from there
on
that seems realistic and as of the month
of february or march if we have more
vaccines approved such as the live
vectored vaccine we may be able to
immunize a larger number of ms like
we're actually getting specific numbers
which i appreciate playing basis
per month operation
warp speed didn't only focus on vaccines
we also looked at therapeutics and we
have worked with a number of companies
developing monoclonal antibodies in
particular
that are able to neutralize the virus
as mr president said we have announced
partnerships with eli lilly with
regeneron and with astrazeneca
and on monday eli lili's monoclonal
antibody was granted an emergency use
authorization to treat the patients that
are
infected and at risk of hospitalization
the regeneron monoclonal antibodies
have been also filed for emergency use
authorization which is currently under
review
and is potentially
reaching approval within the next few
weeks and finally astrazeneca just
in the last few days has received a
green light to start
two large phase three trials with their
monoclonal antibodies
supported by operation warp speed to
prevent uh the acquisition of covid19
disease
in very frail subjects or
in very high risk subjects as a
protective
alternative to a vaccine so
potentially two vaccines and two
therapeutics may be granted an emergency
use authorization
before the end of this year
i think it's a remarkable achievement
within a period of six to seven months
it is important to note that this
progress has been achieved without
any political interference i said it
many times
and at every step has been well the
interference has been
pushing for early euas rather than just
leading
letting things run their course the
trials or whether
when the data safety monitoring boards
review the safety of the studies on an
ongoing basis
and sometimes put them on hold as i'm
sure you have
witnessed with the astrazeneca vaccine
for instance
and these same data safety monitoring
boards
are the independent boards of experts
that analyze the efficacy
of the vaccines and the safety of the
vaccines
and tell the companies whether uh they
should progress
with the filing of an emergency use
authorization
or not so it's not the companies it's
not operation warp speed
it's not the us government it is
independent experts
that assess the safety and the efficacy
of the vaccines
that are being tested and when the fda
will review these vaccines
and this therapeutics they will
also have the advice public advice
from boards one of them is called the
verpack that is the advisory board to
the fda for vaccine reviews
uh on after review of the of the of the
data
transparently and available to everybody
to look into
before the fda then make its decision to
either authorize a vaccine
or not authorize it on that basis i
personally feel very comfortable to say
that the vaccines and the therapeutics
that we have helped developed and
accelerate
will be judged independently and if
approved should be used by
all in the population because i believe
vaccination is likely to be the
cornerstone
among all the other measures that we
have to take well yeah
to help us really control this pandemic
i will now pass to my co-leader general
perna who will tell you more about
the support that the operation has
provided to i wonder if trump's even
their vaccine and also
to their distribution i wonder if trump
left while this was going on to later
not have questions yelled at him i mean
i just have no idea
mr president thank you for uh we'll
still be there continue service
of our great nation as the co-leader
with dr monsef salawi on this mission
uh let me start by emphasizing for me
what is operational warp speed about
it is about saving lives and it is a
herculean task
uh that the president put us on many
months ago
uh and as dr salawi just laid out we are
making steady progress
uh and we are ready to execute through
the whole of american approach it's like
the whole cast
has been replaced now in federal
government
local states industry and academia
to expand the capacity and capability to
achieve
our mission it has been powerful
we have capitalized on the best
contracting
logistics and planning experts available
to synchronize and integrate all phases
of the operation
from development of the vaccine
manufacturing of the vaccine
and finally distribution of the vaccine
six months ago the capacity did not
exist
in our nation's pharmaceutical
production base
we went to work building brick and
mortar manufacturing facilities
bringing in the right specialized
machinery and equipment
and prioritizing supply chain
materials through the defense production
act
today we expect to have tens of millions
of doses
immediately following eua and we will
distribute them
as soon as the fda
applies to eua okay we will do that
within 24 hours
of the eua we are harnessing the
strength of commercial industry
and existing vaccine delivery
capabilities
and infrastructure our nation deserves
this vaccines will be allocated pro-rata
by population
so that we ensure fair and equitable
across
we need the states who are part of the
planning
to accept the vaccine
pro-rata working closely along with the
cdc
the 64 jurisdictions and states to
ensure vaccine can safely and quickly
get to those
who need it first and then we have plans
to ensure that it spreads exponentially
across
our country and that no place is left
without a vaccine
at the end of the day our success is
going to be judged
by the availability of the vaccine as
shots go in arms it is
the partnerships we have formed with the
pharmaceutical companies like pfizer
and moderna distribution companies like
mckesson
fedex and ups and pharmacies like cvs
and walgreens that have agreed to do
things differently to think how can we
get this to the american people
in the most rapid and expedition
expeditionist
yeah it does feel like this is an event
they put together to sort of make trump
feel a little bit better america
approach this collaboration this effort
that everybody is leading towards
i will end where i started this is about
saving lives
the lives of the great american people
and we will not rest
until we are successful and that we have
irreversible momentum to returning our
nation
back to normal thank you mr president
wow
general very much great job alex
pleasure
oh this is alex azar now secretary of
hhs and a real sycophant
thank you mr president for providing the
leadership that's gotten us where we are
today
here we go the success that operation
warp speed has realized so far has been
made possible
only because of the bold vision you
announced not even six months ago
right here in the rose garden to
highlight three of the remarkable
accomplishments we've seen just this
week
first pfizer announced very promising
data on its vaccine candidate
second eli the second the fda authorized
and we have begun to distribute and
administer eli lilly's monoclonal
antibody
to help americans at risk for serious
disease
stay out of the hospital third another
vaccine company moderna announced that
it's reached a critical
clinical trial milestone meaning we may
see data from them within days
back in the spring we were told by all
of the experts that a vaccine was a year
or a year and a half away and the
announcements i just highlighted would
have been
unthinkable if most people can't get it
till may or june
and they started in february that's more
than a year away
effective vaccine to our most vulnerable
this year
as i worked with the president to
assemble this team and organize this
effort
his support was indispensable at each
step of the way
we went out and found the very best
people on the planet to do the job who
you just talked with
dr slowie the world's most successful
vaccine developer
general purna one of the world's most
qualified logistics leaders
when i first talked to dr slowly and
general purna about our goals and
recruited them to this effort
we dreamed of being at the point we're
at today
on track to achieve the incredibly
ambitious goal we set together
the president gave us the full financial
support i'm sorry to keep interrupting
but this is worthless trash
trump promised 100 million doses in
october it's like what happened to the
100 million doses in october guys
our completely unprecedented partnership
with the defense department has given us
a comprehensive public private plan for
distribution
and helped each operation warp speed
vaccine maker secure what they needed
for manufacturing
including pfizer's ongoing production
this week
operation warp speed has always had one
goal saving lives
the president has given ows the
independence it needs to achieve that
goal
and ensure that we're following the
procedures that americans expect for any
medical product they take at every step
ensuring patient safety has been our top
priority
this process has been driven solely by
science and data
so it's a shame that some one example
being the governor of new york i would
never have actually injected politics
into the process
of the possibility of intentionally sure
i'd use that word to an fda
authorized vaccine which is simply
unconscionable
because the president has delivered the
full funding we need the best people on
the planet
and real independence for this project
operation warp speed is doing something
that's never been done before in history
this success means there is light at the
end of the tunnel
right now is not the time to let our
guard down we continue to encourage
americans to follow the three w's
wash your hands watch your distance wear
a mask when you can't watch your
distance
and avoid settings where you can't do
those things because of the incredible
american spirit
because of what great scientists and
public servants and innovators have done
through operation warp speed
we have such a bright future ahead of us
if we continue to protect ourselves our
families and our communities that i
firmly believe that future will be here
very soon thank you mr president for
making that
very bright future possible for the
american people
all right thank you mike pence please
now mike pence and i would be shocked if
he takes
a single question
well thank you mr president and on
behalf of the white house coronavirus
task force
signing off i was grateful to just have
a few minutes today to commend
the team of operation warp speed
it was your vision that we could harness
the ingenuity and the creativity
of america's greatest pharmaceutical and
research companies
to speed in record time uh a vaccine
that would save
american lives oh man told the american
people that we would have a vaccine
before the end of the year and
some scoffed at that timetable but i can
tell you the team on operation warp
speed
didn't these great research companies
didn't
and as you've articulated here mr
president articulated american people
can be comforted
with all the news this week that help is
on the way
that literally pending fda approval
of the pfizer vaccine and uh perhaps
very soon
another vaccine that will be submitted
by moderna and even other companies that
before the year is out we'll be able to
administer a vaccine to tens of millions
of americans as you've said mr president
beginning with those most vulnerable
beginning with our
seniors all across this country
beginning with our health care workers
and
first responders at the point of the
need it is an
unprecedented medical mobilization the
greatest in the history of our country
and i join you in commending the state
you're so great let me also say mr
president that uh the white house
coronavirus task force will be
meeting with our nation's governors in
our regular conference call this monday
we'll be reviewing with them the
progress on the development of a vaccine
our plans for distribution
but we'll also be reviewing each and
every state's specific plans for
distributing the vaccine
continue to urge governors who have
those plans
developed and prepared and ready for
immediate implementation
and finally mr president as we see cases
rising around the country as we see
hospitalizations rising around the
country oh he admits that okay i want to
encourage the american people with the
news
that as we have done from the very
beginning we're going to continue to
move heaven and earth
to make sure that your family has access
to the level of health care
that we'd want any one of our members
when he says you are he means trump's
family
today and as we heard reported at our
last task force meeting mr president
uh we're receiving requests from states
for ppe
for personnel but we're meeting all of
those requests
and according to our team on the ground
we continue to believe that we'll be
able to meet the request for ppe
and equipment both from the strategic
national stockpile
also from the commercial market to make
sure that those needs
are all met right the american people
can also be confident because of the
system that you established that
since this past july we're actually able
to track ppe
gowns and gloves and n95 masks on a
hospital
by hospital basis so we can continue to
deliver as you said mr president
trump implemented that extraordinary
record in america where
no american who's ever required a
ventilator has ever been denied
a ventilator no american who's ever
acquired an icu bed
yeah the the audience of this
presentation from pence is trump this is
not useful to the media
speed mr president his help is on the
way it's on the way right around the
corner
uh as one of the members of our task
force said recently the
cavalry is coming but we want to
encourage every american let's see if he
takes questions
i say no our health care system has the
resources to support
the equipment and supplies that they
need and we also
mr president as as we see cases rising
particularly in
in the heartland of this country but in
communities all across america we
encourage every american as the
secretary did
as you have continue to practice good
hygiene
wash your hands practice social
distancing wear a mask when that's
not possible we all have a role to play
we all know what to do
to protect the vulnerable and to look
after our families and our neighbors and
friends and we encourage
every american with all the good news
this week
to continue to be persistent in putting
the health of yourself
your family your neighbors co-workers
kind of phoning it in
and and we'll get through this and we'll
get through this together
but thank you mister with a different
president though and thank you everybody
thank you very much
and there it is
[Applause]
and off they go okay so uh
there it is um why don't we take a few
phone calls i do uh
everybody's been so great supporting we
just hit a hundred thousand live viewers
during that
on uh youtube that's never happened
before
one hundred thousand so if you're headed
out make sure to hit that subscribe
button so that in the future you'll be
uh notified when i go live uh what's
going on here this is strange
um thought this was gonna keep going
yeah and uh if you're heading out hit
the subscribe button hit the follow
button etc but i would love to hear from
some of you guys davidpakman.com
discord is the place if you want to talk
to me get into the waiting lobby
very strong stream and so i want to go
right to the phones
i know some folks will leave but i would
love for you to stay we're going to hear
from some of our viewers hopefully all
over the world
remember you go to davidpakman.com
discord
you get into the waiting lobby and then
you change your nickname
to location colon name location
colon name that's the way that it works
let's go
first powerfully and directly to amy in
ohio amy in ohio you're on the air
amy in ohio please unmute you were on
the air
hello yes that's you
yes that's you amy you are on the air
riveting stuff amy it sounds like you're
probably listening on youtube or twitch
instead of
in discord but you've got to listen in
discord remember
um let's go next to emilio in lawrence
emilio in lawrence you're on the air
hey can you hear me yes i can what's
going on what's going on david
greetings from you lawrence
massachusetts greetings
well i'm actually in l.a so i'm telling
a little bit of a lie but uh
i'm from lawrence so beautiful throw
that massachusetts connection
love yeah i had a question that's not
necessarily related to
any of this crazy election fraud stuff
i had a question about georgia okay yeah
i just wanted to hear what your thought
was you know flipping georgia
you know in addition to arizona those
are really big deals and
a lot of that was because of the
minority vote uh you know
community support and so i was wondering
if
through additional support we might be
able to see a blue wave in the south
like if that's a flash in the pan what
happened in georgia or
there's no way to answer that i mean you
know every election anytime there's a
flip or a state everybody starts to
project well if you look at demographic
changes than this or if you look at
changes to the party platform than that
i mean we really we just have to do the
work and i prefer to take it a step at a
time
so step one is can we take
these senate seats in georgia that
should be the focus for the next
seven weeks or however long it is we'll
think about flipping more seats
you know for 2022 and beyond right but
we have
and i don't want to take too much time
but we have like yang going down there
yeah
which i love definitely like investment
happening absolutely tangible change so
yeah thanks man all right thank you very
much appreciate it
uh yeah we're gonna have to wait and see
that's really the
uh that's really the only way to go
let's go next to kelsey from colorado
kelsey from colorado you're on the air
kelsey you're on the air
kelsey you've got to unmute if you would
like to talk to me you are on the air
though
um that's too bad i was looking forward
to hearing from
kelsey let's go instead
to where are we going instead
there's just a lot of people trying to
get on here
uh why don't we go to um
let's go to kyle from upstate new york
kyle from upstate new york you're on the
air
and kyle bailed oh my god let's go to
tomas from my birth city of buenos aires
oh hi david thomas bienvenido
hi uh i've been following you for a
while
are you american or argentinian i'm from
argentina i live in argentina wow you
have beautiful english
thanks i i've never lived in the us
uh wow just games
i wanted to ask you yeah uh what do you
think
about all the people that like live in
argentina but support trump
not knowing like like kind of projecting
the left and right from argentina onto
the us
yeah my mom was telling me the other day
that she had a friend who doesn't
who lives in argentina she doesn't
really pay that much attention to
politics but she just said
oh you're not voting for trump i mean it
seems like he's sort of doing okay
but it's you know it's people who are
con they're basically tuned out they
don't really seem to know what's going
on
i mean i don't know what to think to be
honest it's you know there's a lot of
americans who have no idea what's going
on politically in any other country
it's not that notable that people in
argentina might not really understand
what's going on in the u.s it's not it's
not hugely surprising
i see the thing is that it bothers me
because i see
argentina supports trump trending in
argentina like every two weeks
oh i haven't that's interesting i've
never you know i watch a lot of
argentinian news every every day and
i've never seen it mentioned at all
that's it must be an online thing
yeah it's just twitter oh i see okay
yeah i mean
you know there's uninformed people even
i know this is hard to imagine tomas
and it's difficult for me to accept but
even in argentina there are some
uninformed people
yeah yeah even more
uninformed people hey uh as far as dulce
de leche what's the what's the top brand
right now that you would recommend
uh i just take la serenissimo i don't
know
i i i'm not really a dulce de leche
person
really yeah wow and
the other day i heard you say that you
prefer chicken milanesa over
absolutely night and day i i just hate
you
now i i have to unsubscribe really then
how did you know i was live
um bye-bye
okay we'll talk to you later thank you
uh that one wrapped up quick that that
turned around real quick let's go to
that's what we call
unsubscribe trolls unsubscribed trolls
very very familiar with that we've
experienced it
um it can be a mind virus it can be a
mind virus
let me go next to okay a lot of people
liking
liking that one why don't we go next to
um i would like to go oh this is
interesting let's go to caitlyn from
alaska
caitlyn from alaska you're on the air
i know that guy was kidding by the way i
know we were both kidding
caitlyn from alaska though i would love
to hear from you if you can unmute
yourself
you just did oh okay cool
hi um so not a lot of people touch
on alaska politics i think you're one of
the few people i've actually heard
um talk or even mention the name of any
of our politicians
absolutely unfortunately sarah palin
right
so yesterday uh it was reported that don
young
has coveted 19. and i'm not somebody who
wishes that on anyone
right i don't think anybody is you're
not a sociopath yeah
but what happens if he does
die after his re-election does the
republican party
then um put somebody else up to take his
place
or how does that work let me see so the
only complexity would be
okay so he's been he's he won
but he wouldn't be sworn in to the
current he wouldn't be sworn in
until the next session starts in january
so
right now it's really still his previous
term
so would someone be selected by the
governor
just for the rest of this term and then
there would be a special election
you know i don't know the answer to that
there's some there's complicated timing
because
if it were after he's actually sworn in
for the next term i think it would be
different
um so what happens if it's after
he after someone's sworn in if it's
after sworn in the governor appoints
someone and then there's a special
election
okay yeah okay awesome thank you so much
i appreciate that
my pleasure i i i appreciate the phone
call great to hear from you
let's go next to um
[Music]
let's go to andre from italy andre from
italy you're on the air where in italy
are you calling from
uh hello yes you're on the air here in
rome rome
wow i love rome uh yeah we're
uh it's me and my girlfriend we we watch
all the time we um
uh we we're studying here from
in an american university we're doing uh
international global politics are you
italian or are you american
no no uh well i'm actually russian but
my girlfriend here is
uh american iranian
say hi hello
good all right yes i can hear you yeah
we're here in rome where international
political science students
love it well what's on your mind today
you actually asked the question don't
mean
oh okay uh so i have a question about
actually your thoughts on the
recent uae deal uh as an american
iranian you know
uh the uae deal and a lot of trump's
politics in the middle east has been
aggressive towards iran so i wanted to
know your opinion on the recent
developments in the region to be
perfectly frank you know i think it's
much ado about nothing it's
you know trump uh of course falsely
claimed he has
five and even ten more peace deals
coming i don't think he could name that
many countries in the region even
um i think that uh it's not
i mean you know i think the proof is in
the following
when the deal happened there were all
sorts of people saying
this just secured trump's reelection
nobody talked about it it barely even i
don't even know that it came up in a
single debate
it was really much a do about nothing
geopolitically and from the standpoint
of the us
and you know he lost and he's not going
to be doing five more peace deals and
he's not going to be doing 10 more peace
deals
yeah yeah i would i would definitely
agree thank you
thank you so much for having us on we've
been calling in for a while
long time viewers first time callers
glad you were able to get on today
thank you thank you all right take care
wow perfect phone call from italy
let's go next back to buenos aires let's
go to
flavio from buenos aires
yes i can
not sure if you can hear me or not um
how are you doing
good how are you
you're on the air right now okay so
um sorry i'm i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna talk i i have no
i can't hear you but everybody seems to
be hearing me anyway
uh the only thing i wanted to say is by
the way i'm from buenos aires i live in
seattle now
one thing that that i'm concerned is
about if you
read the article uh by barton gelman
the i know you did because you did you
did a show about that
it's sort of playing uh right now but
everybody seems to be discarding the
possibility of a coup by trump
essentially by the republicans in
enabling him without um
conceding the election uh i just wanted
to to know what your
thoughts are around that so you're
talking about the the
elector coup strategy right
right essentially delaying uh the
certification by any means
necessary can save hardware date present
competing sets of electors by both
parties
then having mitch i'm sorry not mitch
but
uh mike pence uh being the one who
decides
which electors count well the thing is
that i don't
there's some complexity to it because
does my i'm not sure that does mike
pence get to decide which electors count
i mean i understand the idea that you
could get state legislatures to send
different electors i don't think it will
happen
but i i'm less familiar with how mike
pence gets to decide which electors
count
yeah so it would have to be it's it's
definitely unclear i'm not an expert by
reading a couple
a couple of articles um there's a
there's that article then there's the
accountguy.com which
sort of explains the same yeah um
it would have to be in the presence of
the house obviously at that point nancy
pelosi would
walk out and not provide quorum so we
will have a constitutional crisis but
um i don't know i i just
feel that a lot of people are just
ignoring this as it cannot happen it
cannot happen
uh but well i don't think it's we don't
have to ignore it
i think it's fine to understand it but
you know i think joe biden's going to be
inaugurated on january 20th i really do
yeah yeah i hope so too
are a lot of argentinians in seattle
um no no muchos um
all right so tough to get sandwiches
amiga there in uh seattle
let's go next oh this should be very
interesting let's go to madalina
from romania madelina from romania
hi hi how are you i'm good
um i wasn't expecting to be picked
but uh i wanted the i haven't been uh
it's the first time i actually viewed
your stream and
viewed anything from your channel and
you're already on the air with me that's
crazy
well i just searched live streams and i
saw the one with
trump speaking and i wanted to see what
that's what
i'm counting on that's exactly that's a
perfect path
in i love it thank you uh i wanted to
ask
what will happen to the mentality of the
trump supporters that
voted for him the 17 million people that
voted for
uh trump um what will happen to their
mentality and how will
they um take on
joe biden and his different uh
procedures and ideas in the future
will they be open to his ideas or will
they still be uh against him
since they are conservatives and most of
them will be against them so
i i think you're going to see trumpists
divided up into a bunch of different
groups you'll get people who never
really followed politics before trump
who will go back to not following
politics you'll see the sort of like
q conspiracy types continue to
conspiracy you know make conspiracy
theories about joe biden
you'll see some who will just go back to
being kind of normal republicans
pretending they care about the debt
pretending they care about you know who
the hell knows what they pretend to care
about these days
the 72 million are all going to go in
different directions i think
i understand yeah um so
joe biden will not most likely
change most of the people's opinions
i've seen a lot in the
footage about uh in different uh
strings and different news coverage of
very young people uh chanting and being
part of the of the camp what attracts
them so much about
trump that they are willing to undermine
democracy
in the same manner that trump endorses
well a lot you have to understand a lot
of them don't know a thing about
undermining democracy they don't know
what the hell is going on
they just see trump as the leader and
they do whatever he says
and he can do no wrong so you're trying
to apply a certain amount of critical
thinking and saying wow look at these
people
who are constitutional conservatives and
yet they see trump doing this stuff and
they ignore
they don't know what the hell they're
showing up and chanting you know
fire fouchy so these are not people
thinking about politics the way you're
thinking about it you know madelina
i understand um okay
so i'm gonna i'm gonna
leave you to uh ask some other people
you're going elsewhere very good
what's happening what's happening in
romania right now
right now i am working and i am
uh i was just taking the time to uh
listen to the
uh discord channel that's all wow well
thank you please call again madalina
okay
okay thank you pleasure very very nice
call there
um a lot a lot happening guys as you can
see a lot a lot happening
let's go to jay from huntsville alabama
oh hey can you hear me yes i can hey
how's it going
good sorry i'm having to uh
move right quick i didn't think i'd
actually get on the show
i was as shocked as you were so um
i love your show thank you obviously not
a trump supporter i had to leave my
office right quick because i'm
surrounded by them
oh do they not know does your office not
know you're not a trump guy
oh they do it's just it's
it's a very tense situation down here
yeah
and i guess
it could have been triggering for you to
do this phone call in front of them
you're saying
good god yeah um also i'm sorry i know
you're live i'll try to make sure i
don't accidentally
say a bad word uh my question is i don't
want to
keep you too long how do we how do we
get
to where erica isn't so divided at this
point like
i don't know how you get someone who's
so
radicalized and i'm telling you they are
radicalized down here it's
scary where do we go from here once
biden
gets in office i have no idea i
i do not i have no clue i mean you know
you have people who think biden's a
pedophile for example
and um trump is you know fighting
pedophilia
i mean i don't know how you do it and
you know there's this idea you just give
them facts well no we know that doesn't
work
we just know that does not it doesn't
evolve that doesn't work my cousin is a
qa non-conspiracy theorist and
it's like talking to i don't i don't
know how to describe it
well a caller the other day a caller the
other day made an interesting point and
he said
you know i spent time with a trump
lunatic a cue
conspiracy theorist and i disabused them
of their beliefs and i said yeah how
long did they take they said it took
three hours on a youtube stream
so the question is like what is the
wholesale strategy for doing it to 72
million people
i mean i don't think we have to do it at
72 million no you only need to do it to
a fraction that's a fair point that's a
fair point
and so i just wanted to let everybody
know in the world not everybody from
alabama is
as the stereotype goes and i voted for
doug jones and joe biden and i love your
show
i'll let someone else get on but uh
thank you for
what you do it's nice to get news that
isn't
completely biased and as unbiased as
possible well you know i was
almost in alabama once because i went to
visit my friends in pensacola florida
and we went out on a boat and started
boating west and we got
damn close to alabama waters but we did
turn back
just short of it i will admit i mean
there's there's plenty of good people
down here but it really is
i just i'm having trouble just trying to
describe it now i had plans on what i
was going to say but it it's just
it's hard to describe it's like seeing
two realities at once
let me ask you this you know how there's
the stereotype of like when you go
to the third wave coffee shop
you know you've got lgbt employees and
everybody's liberal and all this
different stuff
if you go to such a place in alabama is
it
is it still like right wingers running
it or does that still exist in a place
like alabama
you know that's a good that's a good
that's a good uh
that's a good suggestion so there's a a
gaming store down here
and it's very lgbtq friendly and stuff
like that but
it is ran by more conservative people i
think when it comes to businesses
they're going to be more open and
accepting but then there's still going
to be businesses like chick-fil-a that
will
fire lgbtq uh people or stuff like that
if somebody
which you can legally do in alabama
right the lgbt is not a protected uh
employment class yeah
wow yeah unfortunately and that's why
i'm in my car now got it okay good
well listen very enlightening and i
appreciate the call
all right you take care all right you
too wow what a call what a call from uh
alabama that is some serious stuff
happening there
let's go next to so that was huntsville
um wait there was another caller that i
was sort of
thinking of going to let me see if i can
find them
uh where was that oh you know what
let's go to nikki from london i mean is
this london england london ontario
london connecticut hi yeah it's uh
london in england i'm actually scottish
but i am
calling from london and england and i
can't believe i've gone it's awesome
really nice to talk to you likewise the
pleasure is all mine
yeah wow um one of the things i said the
talk
that trump did today do you think that's
because since president-elect
joe biden got called on saturday
there's been a lot of talk in the press
about
him forming the committee getting all
the scientists together and
how he's really been um you know
tackling covert and that it's one of his
priorities and
a lot of press around that and of course
the vaccine has been announced that
that's why
trump's come out and done this today is
to kind of
try and steal biden's press
about covered away from him it may be i
mean to me it felt more like a pity
party to be totally honest with you
nikki it seems sort of like
trump's been hiding for nine days and
they put together it's almost like um
it's almost like imagine that if you
were dealing with someone who
wasn't cognitively there who was it oh i
think it was trump's dad
when trump's dad had more serious
dementia i think that they set up a
phone in trump's dad's office and it
would just go to his receptionist
and he thought he was doing business
exactly it almost feels like it was the
same thing done for trump today
but i did notice what you noticed that
at one point
it was almost as if he very nearly said
the biden administration yes he almost
accidentally conceded i think yeah
yeah it really did so it's well it gives
you a little bit of hope
it does hey listen i recently watched a
show
with a terrific scottish actress okay
are you familiar with the actress kelly
mcdonald
and to be fair
i've got when it comes to actors and
actresses unless they're mega famous
i i i remember real life i don't
remember
tv or films it's my massive weak spot
i've got oh my goodness
well in any case let me i will um five
minutes later i've forgotten it
i will issue a recommendation the
program
girihaji on netflix
perfect program could you say it again
it's it's giri slash [ __ ] it's japanese
okay and and this scottish actress
uh kelly mcdonald is in it and it's a
tremendous program
well i'll put that on my watch list
absolutely absolutely nikki
a real pleasure likewise thank you so
much
wow guys what a perfect phone call um
tough to imagine anything that could
beat that so that's going to do it for
me i really appreciate everybody who
joined
make sure on the way out subscribe
to the youtube channel it's free follow
me on twitch it costs
nothing make sure to give us a like on
facebook and we'll be back very soon
i may do some streaming of the million
maga rally tomorrow
i i may not i don't know what i have
going on tomorrow it's supposed to be a
sunny day so we're going to be doing a
lot of
vitamin d acceptance but um
we may be doing a little million maga
tomorrow i'll otherwise see you guys
very soon
you